the fda warning of a possible link
between the johnson and johnson covet
vaccine and a rare autoimmune
nerve disorder known as gylon barret
syndrome the fda is reporting 100 cases
of the rare disorder now that's out of
approximately 12.5 million people who
have gotten the shot
let's bring in fox news contributor dr
mark siegel so tell us like
what's the what's the rate of risk here
um when you weigh
getting the vaccine and also what does
that mean for the johnson johnson
vaccine going forward
all excellent questions dana good
morning it's about 13 million people
have gotten the j and j
shot but only 5 million since april when
they had to scare about blood clots
and we're talking about 100 cases even
if it's linked to the vaccine 100 cases
out of a total of 13 million so it's
extremely extremely rare and i want to
point out
that covet itself gives you this
autoimmune condition where literally
you get weakness and some loss of
sensation it's almost
always temporary by the way it's scary
when you have it but it's almost
only always temporary so i don't think
that this is a reason not to take the j
and j
shot but only about eight percent of
people that have taken the vaccine have
been focused on the j j because they
want one and done
most of the vaccines have been the mrna
the pfizer
and the modernist shots and what i
really don't want to have happen here
is that this contributes to already the
vaccine hesitancy problem
we have in the united states at a time
when the delta variant is emerging
and it's over 65 of cases and it's going
through the unvaccinated population so
this is very very rare you can get it
from the virus itself you can get it
from a common bacteria
there's about 10 in a million cases per
year as it is
of this guillain-barre syndrome this
doesn't really change the equation for
the j
and j shot though it will clearly change
public perception so that was my
question you still recommend getting the
shot
would you recommend it for everyone or
is there any
medical or physical indicator for an
individual person
that might might give them a warning
before
if they were susceptible perhaps to this
nervous condition
you know bill that's an excellent
question so i would say people that have
had guillain-barre before and i just
told you we see it from other
indications i wouldn't recommend that
they get this shot absolutely not
and we'd have that debate every day
because we've seen guillain-barre
associated with flu shots potentially
with a shingle shot
so it's a condition that we see
associated with viruses bacteria and
vaccines
but i so this wouldn't change me and by
the way i want everyone out there to
know
if you had the johnson and johnson shot
and you didn't have a complication
you're not going to suddenly get it now
it doesn't suddenly occur months later
that's good to know